FELIPE HOFFA: Data in BigQuery
is always encrypted at rest
by default. But some projects
may have a requirement
to manage its own keys.
On Cloud Key Management Service,
I just gave BigQuery access
to read one of my own keys.
And I copied that key's
ID to use in the query.
[INAUDIBLE] BigQuery.
When I choose a destination
table for a query,
I can choose which
encryption type to use.
To use my own keys, I can select
Customer Managed Encryption.
And I can give it the ID of
the key we just got from KMS.
The [INAUDIBLE] files
show that this new table
is encrypted with my key.
Because a key
lives in Cloud KMS,
I can query this
tablet as usual.
Let's try that.
As long as I have access to this
key, my existing [INAUDIBLE]
will run unaffected.
And this is how you can easily
encrypt data stored in BigQuery
using your own keys.